i had two mad crushes in the last month
which is really good for me yeah but it
turns out you know one of them is
married to
the mother of some friends of mine
because you want to believe that oh
maybe this relationship that they're in
is temporary or maybe they'll die i
always think oh gosh couldn't that
person just die martha stewart is making
some shocking confessions about her love
life oh well yeah very while appearing
on chelsea handler's dear chelsea
podcast the lifestyle guru opened up
about her current relationship status
and things got pretty candid i had two
mad crushes in the last month which is
really good for me yeah but it turns out
you know one of them is married to
the mother of some friends of mine and
and i just
he's so attractive but you don't you
can't be a homewrecker no i'm not i've
never been a home recorder no never and
i've tried really hard not to be it's
hard i've had the opportunity yeah
and i have not taken anybody up on it
and that's really where that's where i
meet men they're all they're all married
to friends of mine or something like
that chelsea tries to put a positive
spin on it but martha makes this grim
joke because i think there are certain
ages we go through where it's very
tempting because you want to believe
that oh maybe this relationship that
they're in is temporary or maybe they'll
die i always think oh gosh couldn't that
person just die the wife yeah not not
painfully just die and then slowly pass
away yeah dark martha very dark but
we're going to chalk this up to the 80
year old sense of humor it's all in fun
if we take a look back martha has had
quite a dating history she was
previously married to entrepreneur
andrew stewart for 26 years until they
split in 1987. martha was later linked
to sir anthony hopkins but she told
ellen degeneres why things didn't work
out between them i have a big scary
house in maine that's
way by itself on 100 acres in the forest
and
i couldn't even imagine taking anthony
hopkins there
yeah i couldn't because all i could
think of was him eating you know right
wait did you date him yeah and you
stopped because of that yeah
i ate his liver with some fava beans and
a nice chianti
oh and get this martha also told andy
cohen back in december she once went on
a date with larry king but by accident i
thought we were just talking about
journalism
et cetera
and then he sort of started got a little
amorous larry king was not my type
romantically okay so larry and martha
not a love match but we have a feeling
dating isn't too hard for the lifestyle
expert especially after she posted this
poolside pic in 2020 that took the
internet by storm you know they were
calling that photo of you a thirst trap
photo do you know what a thirst trap is
i don't even know what that is no what
is it
a thirst trap is when you put out a very
sexy image that you know
folks are going to appreciate and get a
bit of reaction
that's definitely a thirst trap yeah and
last year she revealed that pick
resulted in many propositions and even
proposals oh i got so many proposals and
so many per you know propositions
but i had to ignore all of them i'm a
very busy person so yeah martha we got
the joke maybe they'll die i always
think oh gosh couldn't that person just
die the wife yeah not not painfully just
die and then slowly pass away yeah but
here's hoping martha finds a partner the
traditional good old-fashioned way
[Music]
you